You know those stories that just live in your brain rent-free, like family legends, historical facts?
你知道有些故事就像白白住在你的脑海里一样，比如家族传奇、历史事实？
The kind of thing everybody swears is true because we've heard it all a million times.
那种每个人都发誓绝对是真的事情，因为我们已经听过无数遍了。
And then one day someone starts asking questions and suddenly the story gets a little wobbly.
然后有一天，有人开始提出疑问，突然之间，这个故事就变得有点站不住脚了。
That's the idea behind the new podcast, Family Lore.
这就是新播客《家族传说》的创意所在。
It's a podcast that takes those big inherited narratives and pulls them apart.
这是一个将那些庞大的代代相传的故事进行剖析的播客。
Not to dismantle them just for the sake of it, but to better understand the whole making of story.
不是为了否定而否定，而是为了更好地理解故事的整个构建过程。
Coming up, we've got a preview of the family lore episode titled If Mosquito Hawks Can Fly.
接下来，我们将为您预告《家族传说》的一集，题为《如果大黄蜂会飞》。
It follows one family's story claiming that their grandfather took flight before the Wright brothers.
它讲述了一个家族的故事，他们声称自己的祖父在莱特兄弟之前就已经飞上蓝天。
Take a listen.
请听。
You might remember back in 1999, the United States Mint started producing specialty quarters.
你可能还记得在1999年，美国铸币局开始发行特种25美分硬币。
On the back of each quarter, instead of an eagle spreading its wings and looking off to the side, you'd see a unique design representing any given state.
在每枚硬币的背面，不再是一只展翅欲飞并向一侧张望的老鹰，而是一个代表特定州的独特设计。
For example, on the back of the Massachusetts quarter, you'd have a minute man.
例如，在马萨诸塞州25美分硬币的背面，你会看到一个民兵。
The Virginia quarter featured ships arriving at Jamestown in 1607.
弗吉尼亚州的硬币上则是1607年船只抵达詹姆斯敦的图案。
And on the back of the North Carolina quarter, you had a man lying prostrate on a primitive airplane, with another man watching from below.
而在北卡罗来纳州硬币的背面，有一个人趴在一架原始飞机上，另一个人在下方观看。
This, of course, was a depiction of of the Wright brothers and their inaugural flight at the small beach town of Kitty Hawk.
这当然是对莱特兄弟以及他们在基蒂霍克这个小海滨小镇进行首飞的描绘。
At the top of the coin is the inscription, First Flight.
硬币顶部刻有“首次飞行”的字样。
This is a story that virtually all Americans know.
这是一个几乎所有美国人都知道的故事。
The Wright brothers were the first to fly.
莱特兄弟是第一个飞上蓝天的人。
The Wright brothers invented the airplane.
莱特兄弟发明了飞机。
Or at the very least, the Wright brothers were pioneers in the field of aviation.
或者至少，莱特兄弟是航空领域的先驱。
But there's another story you probably haven't heard that makes the origins of American aviation a little more complex.
但还有一个你可能没听过的故事，它让美国航空的起源变得更加复杂。
I'm Lloyd Lockridge.
我是劳埃德·洛克里奇。
And this is Family Lore.
这里是《家族传说》。
This story begins in Louisiana, a state not known for aviation.
这个故事始于路易斯安那州，一个并不以航空闻名的州。
Quite the opposite, really.
事实上，恰恰相反。
With its bayous swamps, labyrinthine coastline, and the nation's biggest river, the state is known for its boats.
这里有沼泽、迷宫般的海岸线以及全美最大的河流，这个州以船只闻名。
Cajun P.
卡津人P。
Rogues, flat-bottom airboats, paddle steamers, the Higgins boat.
罗格船、平底气垫船、明轮蒸气船、希金斯船。
But the Louisiana man at the center of this episode's family lore was not interested in boats.
但本集家族传说核心的那位路易斯安那州人对船只并不感兴趣。
He was not interested in navigating the water.
他对在水上航行不感兴趣。
the advent of airplanes, this man dreamed of navigating the sky.
随着飞机的出现，这个人梦想着在天空中航行。
His name was Charles Frederick Page.
他的名字叫查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇。
And to hear his story, we have traveled to Alexandria, Louisiana in person to speak with one of his descendants, Charles Frederick Page's grandson.
为了听他的故事，我们亲自来到了路易斯安那州的亚历山大市，采访了他的后代之一——查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的孙子。
Joseph Page is 87 years old.
约瑟夫·佩奇今年87岁。
He's a veteran of the United States Air Force and his military background shows.
他是美国空军退伍军人，他的军人背景显而易见。
His house is tidier than a nuclear submarine.
他的房子比核潜艇还要整洁。
And Mr. Page stands with a certain posture, one that conveys not only physical strength, but a kind of strength of character.
佩奇先生站立时有一种特殊的姿态，这种姿态不仅传达出身体的力量，还传达出一种品格的力量。
He's the kind of person who, without saying a word, makes you want to take your hat off when you walk inside.
他是那种无需多言，就能让你一进门就想脱帽致敬的人。
We were greeted by him and his wife of 65 years.
我们受到了他和结发65年的妻子的迎接。
We sat down in his living room and immediately launched into a conversation about his early life.
我们在他的起居室坐下，随即开始了关于他早年生活的交谈。
Well, I grew up on hybrid 20s in Pineville, so we lived in a country and about a hundred yards away.
嗯，我在派恩维尔的混合20年代长大，所以我们住在乡下，大约一百码远的地方。
Joseph came of age in 1950s Louisiana, an overtly and unapologetically racist environment.
约瑟夫在20世纪50年代的路易斯安那州度过青春期，这是一个公开且毫不掩饰的种族主义环境。
Despite living in Pineville, he had to commute across the Red River to Alexandria in order to attend the only all-black school in the area.
尽管住在派恩维尔，他必须乘车穿过红河前往亚历山大，才能就读于该地区唯一的全黑人学校。
And to add insult to injury, even if he were the first person at the municipal bus stop, he'd have to wait for all the white passengers to board first, only to pass them all on his way to the back of the bus.
更糟糕的是，即便他是市政公交车站的第一个乘客，他也必须等所有白人乘客先上车，然后在走到车尾的路上从他们身边经过。
Indigities like that were a part of daily life.
诸如此类的侮辱是日常生活的一部分。
And this kind of blatant discrimination was a confusing experience for young Joseph Page, because his neighbors out in the country were white, and he'd play with his neighbors all the time.
这种赤裸裸的歧视对年轻的约瑟夫·佩奇来说是一段令人困惑的经历，因为他在乡下的邻居是白人，而且他经常和邻居们一起玩。
But if they saw each other in the town of Alexandria, they'd have to pretend like they didn't know each other.
但如果他们在亚历山大镇碰面，他们就得装作不认识对方。
I didn't quite understand as a child.
我小时候并不是很懂。
In my mind, I knew it was not right as to why we could be friends and hang out together in the country where nobody was around.
在我心里，我很清楚这不对：为什么我们在四周无人乡下可以做朋友、一起玩耍，
But we could not associate with each other when we were in Alexandria.
但在亚历山大市时，我们却不能互相交往。
And as a child, do you remember thinking this doesn't make any sense?
作为一个孩子，你还记得当时觉得这完全讲不通吗？
Yeah, I did.
是的，我记得。
Something was wrong.
有些地方不对劲。
I couldn't exactly put my hands on it.
我当时说不上来具体是什么。
But by the time I got to junior high school, I knew for a fact it was wrong and I recognized it as discrimination." Joseph was grappling with these issues in the midst of a national reckoning.
但到了初中时，我确信这是不对的，并意识到这就是歧视。”约瑟夫在全国上下都在进行反思的时代背景下，正艰难地应对着这些问题。
The Civil Rights Act of 1964 was on the horizon and the movement for racial equality was gaining momentum.
1964年《民权法案》即将出台，争取种族平等的运动正积蓄着势头。
But Joseph had no illusions about the reality of his situation.
但约瑟夫对自己的现实处境并没有抱任何幻想。
Despite the promises of civil rights, Joseph's parents told him that he'd need to work twice as hard as white people to achieve the same results.
尽管民权做出了承诺，但约瑟夫的父母告诉他，他必须付出比白人加倍的努力才能取得同样的成果。
And this was not some abstract lesson.
这可不是什么抽象的道理。
It was inextricably connected to the story of the family's patriarch, Joseph's grandfather, Charles Frederick Page.
它与这个家族的大家长、约瑟夫的祖父查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的故事有着密不可分的联系。
Charles Page was born in 1864 in Rapides Parish, Louisiana.
查尔斯·佩奇于1864年出生在路易斯安那州拉皮德斯帕里什。
He was born into slavery, which means that Joseph Page's grandfather, not his great-great-grandfather, or some distant relative, but his grandfather was, at one point, enslaved.
他出生于奴隶制时期，这意味着约瑟夫·佩奇的祖父——不是他的曾祖父，也不是什么远亲，而是他的祖父——曾经一度是个奴隶。
I said I saw my grandchildren now.
我说我现在看到了我的孙辈们。
She underscored a point of slavery was not that long ago.
她强调了一个观点，即奴隶制其实并没有那么遥远。
Think about that.
想想看。
So tell me what one of the first things you remember learning about your grandfather Charles Frederick Page?
那么请告诉我，你记得关于你祖父查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇的最早的事情之一是什么？
Well my parents and my aunt and uncles always talked about it when I was a small kid.
嗯，当我还是个小孩子的时候，我的父母、姑姑和叔叔们总是在谈论这件事。
He was a bigger than life figure in my mind as a kid.
在我小时候的记忆里，他是一个了不起的传奇人物。
They always told us about inventing in the first airship in case he didn't catch that Joseph said that he was always told that his grandfather invented the first airship had we would go as school kids would do we would go to school to elementary school and say my grandfather built the first airship and the other kids were laughing at us and said you know that's not right the right brothers built the first airplane so as a kid you know when we're embarrassed by your friends right This claim that Charles Frederick Page invented an airship prior to the Wright Brothers inventing the airplane.
他们总是跟我们讲他发明了第一艘飞船的事。如果你没听清的话，约瑟夫说，大家总是告诉他，他的祖父发明了第一艘飞船。我们当时作为小学生的反应是，我们会去上小学，跟人说“我祖父造了第一艘飞船”，然后其他孩子会嘲笑我们，说：“你知道这不对，莱特兄弟造了第一架飞机。”所以作为一个孩子，你知道的，这会让你在朋友面前感到尴尬，对吧？这个说法——即查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇在莱特兄弟发明飞机之前就发明了一艘飞船。
This was a strong piece of Page family lore.
这是佩奇家族口口相传的一段强有力的传说。
It's something the family believes to be true.
这是家族深信不疑的事情。
But a lot of people outside the family are...
但家族之外的许多人却……
skeptical, at best.
充其量也只是持怀疑态度。
Those who knew Charles Page respected him, but for other reasons.
认识查尔斯·佩奇的人都很尊敬他，但原因确是出于其他方面。
He was a Renaissance man.
他是个多才多艺的人。
He was a timberman, a cobbler, a botanical farmer.
他是个伐木工、鞋匠、植物农业家。
He established a cemetery for the Black community in Pineville, the first of its kind, the Lincoln Cemetery.
他在派恩维尔为黑人社区建立了一个墓园，这是同类中的第一个，即林肯公墓。
He had a vision for diversified farming, where a tenant farmer could slowly gain equity in the land he was working.
他对多元化农业有着长远的构想，在那里，佃农可以慢慢获得他所耕种土地的产权。
But what a lot of his peers didn't know is that he also had a mind for engineering.
但他的许多同龄人不知道的是，他同样有着出色的工程头脑。
He would have been a great engineer.
他本来可以成为一名伟大的工程师。
Grandmother used to complain about when she would tell my grandfather, she needed to do chicken coop.
祖母过去常常抱怨，每当她告诉祖父需要一个鸡舍时，
He needed to build her new chicken coop.
他需要为她建造一个新的鸡舍。
He would get out the ruler, and a pencil, and paper, and he would design it, and he would do all this stuff.
他会拿出尺子、铅笔和纸，然后开始设计，做各种各样的事情。
It was like, all I need is a simple chicken coop.
当时的感觉就像是，我需要的仅仅是一个简单的鸡舍。
It did not have to be perfect, you know.
你知道的，它根本不需要那么完美。
But Charles Page had bigger ambitions than state-of-the-art chicken coops.
但查尔斯·佩奇的雄心可不止于最先进的鸡舍。
And one evening, while sitting on his porch, he got an idea from an unlikely contributor, the Mosquito Hawk.
一天傍晚，当他坐在走廊上时，他从一个意想不到的启发者那里得到灵感——大蚊鹰（豆娘）。
Those big, gangly, slow-moving, mosquito-looking insects that you tend to see in the spring and fall.
就是你在春秋两季经常看到的那些巨大、细长、动作迟缓、看起来像蚊子的昆虫。
The story I heard repeatedly was that he was sitting on his porch in the evenings and watched the flight of those mosquito hogs.
我反复听到的故事是，他傍晚坐在走廊里，观察着那些大蚊鹰的飞行。
And that inspired him to figure out how he could duplicate that and fly himself and figure out how to do that.
这启发了他去弄清楚自己该如何复制这种飞行，让自己也能飞起来，并琢磨出该怎么做。
And in the ensuing weeks, months, or even years, nobody knows for sure.
在随后的几个星期、几个月甚至几年里，谁也说不准具体是多久。
Charles Page worked on a way to fly.
查尔斯·佩奇一直在研究飞行的办法。
And he had a deadline.
而且他有一个截止日期。
He needed to design and build something in time for the 1904 Louisiana Purchase Exposition, which was held in St.
他需要在1904年路易斯安那购地博览会开幕前设计并建造出一些东西，那届博览会是在圣
Louis, Missouri.
路易斯，密苏里州举行的。
To hear the full episode and to learn more of Charles Frederick Page's role in the pioneering days of aviation, search for Family Lore wherever you get your podcasts.
想要收听完整节目并深入了解查尔斯·弗雷德里克·佩奇在航空先驱时期的作用，请在您获取播客的平台搜索《Family Lore》（家族传说）。